[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa del espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia kobe 19 a continuación les
presento el sumario de algunos de los
temas que vamos a desarrollar en esta
visión
desde el pasado mes de abril argentina
viene arrastrando un pico constante de
contagio de víctimas de kobe 19 esta
semana las cifras fueron altísimas las
cifras alcanzaron o superaron las 39 mil
de personas contagiadas en 24 horas y
las muertes superaron las 700 por este
motivo el presidente alberto fernández
impuso nuevamente restricciones en ese
país vamos a ver el panorama general de
argentina y también conoceremos a
profundidad cuáles son esas nuevas
restricciones también eeuu buen noticia
esta semana al anunciar que donará 20
millones de dosis de vacunas contra el
cob y 19 este lote está compuesto por
viales de farmacéuticas como modernas
facer variante y johnson y johnson y
será repartido de manera equitativa en
varios países a través del mecanismo
kóvacs y finalmente en nuestra consulta
con el doctor pérez vamos a conversar
sobre el anuncio que hizo la o ms en el
que afirmó que las vacunas existentes ya
en el mercado sirven para hacer frente a
cualquier tipo de las variantes del
coronavirus del cobi 19
vamos a conversar sobre ese pasaporte de
vacunación que entrará en vigor en la
unión europea y también vamos a retomar
el tema de las medidas de bioseguridad
que en muchos países ya han comenzado a
relajarse y las están empezando a dejar
de lado en plena ola de contagio sobre
todo en américa latina pues vamos a
comenzar como ya les decía en suramérica
esta región actualmente es la parte del
mundo con más casos de kobe 19 por
millón de habitantes según el portal
agua world in data que es adjunto a la
universidad johns hopkins los países más
afectados son uruguay con más de 874
casos por millón de habitantes seguido
por argentina con 618 y paraguay con 323
33 en contraste con sus vecinos chile se
posesiona como el segundo país con la
campaña de inmunización más avanzada del
mundo al haber vacunado totalmente es
decir con las dos dosis a poco más del
50 por ciento de la población ya lo
vamos a ver en detalle pero por su parte
registró la cuarta semana consecutiva
con un descenso que ya llega al 20
por ciento en cuanto al número de
contagios y de fallecidos según lo
indicó el centro de información de
epidemiología del ministerio de salud de
perú
y nos vamos a ir ahora a conocer el
balance de la situación de cómo está
terminando la semana algunos de los
puntos en américa latina' vamos a
comenzar en argentina regresaron allí
las restricciones hay un repunte de
casos y llegaron algunos lotes de vacuna
vamos a conversar entonces con natalio
con soy el corresponsal de france 24 en
la ciudad de buenos aires en la capital
argentina
hola natalia hablemos entonces de cómo
está la situación pongámonos en
perspectiva la situación general en
cuanto al pico de contagio esta semana
ya lo decíamos hubo picos superiores a
las 39 mil personas contagiadas y más de
745 personas fallecieron
si esta segunda ola de coronavirus aquí
en argentina es muchísimo más fuerte que
la primera ola que ocurrió en 2020 hay
días con más de 35.000 casos reportados
muchos días seguidos con alrededor de
quinientas muertes por coronavirus
informadas en argentina hay una especial
presión sobre las terapias intensivas en
la ocupación de camas de terapia es la
más alta desde el inicio de la pandemia
en algunos lugares es de más de 75% en
algunos lugares llega el 90 se conocen
muchos casos de gente que necesita
esperar mucho tiempo para conseguir una
cama de hecho si quienes entraban a un
respirador en 2020 en el 56% de los
casos más o menos terminaban falleciendo
ahora esa cifra está por encima del 75%
es un momento muy difícil de la pandemia
en argentina y por eso también el
gobierno decidió implementar
restricciones más fuertes
son muchos los factores que se están
uniendo allí en argentina para que se
esté llegando a esta situación el mismo
presidente alberto fernández dijo que el
país está encarando el momento más
difícil de la pandemia de kobe 19
escuchemos
estamos viviendo
el peor momento desde que comenzó la
pandemia
ustedes saben que recorro el país y
también saben que conozco muy bien las
dificultades que atravesamos
estamos teniendo la mayor cantidad de
casos y de fallecidos
debemos asumir seriamente lo crítico de
este tiempo y no naturalizar tanta
tragedia
más allá de lo que cada uno piense
debemos asumir la gravedad de tinta
antes no es momento de especulaciones
nadie tiene derecho a querer sacar
ventaja
cuando debemos unirnos para superar esta
catástrofe que azota a la humanidad
natalio retomó la comunicación con usted
quiero que profundicemos en esas medidas
que anunció el presidente fernández para
comenzar a hacer frente a este pico de
contagio que fue lo que dijo el
mandatario
si en las zonas de alto riesgo y alarma
epidemiológica prácticamente en todo el
país entre el 22 y el 30 de mayo habrá
fuertes restricciones no podrá haber
actividades económicas sociales
educativas religiosas ni deportivas la
circulación estará restringida
exclusivamente entre las 6 de la mañana
y las 6 de la tarde con una movilidad
que se le pide a la población sea cerca
de su domicilio por supuesto hay
excepciones como siempre el personal de
salud las fuerzas de seguridad a los
comercios esenciales por ejemplo los
supermercados y también en algunos casos
por ejemplo en la ciudad buenos aires
restaurantes y bares van a poder atender
de la puerta para afuera con envíos a
domicilio o gente retirando en el local
la comida pero este cierre es un cierre
como digo bastante más estricto con un
compromiso de las autoridades de tratar
de que se cumpla y de tratar hacer
controles más fuertes de los que se
venían haciendo hasta ahora porque había
dificultades en el cumplimiento de las
estaban vigentes hasta el momento este
cierre estricto luego de esta primera
etapa se volverá a repetir en el primer
fin de semana de junio además
natalia hablamos ahora de el avance de
la vacunación en argentina porque si
bien vemos que continúan llegando lotes
de vacunas procedentes de rusia y
también de china la vacunación en
argentina se muestra muy lenta sobre
todo si se compara con otros países de
la región que lo que sucede allí
hasta el 20 de mayo se había vacunado
con al menos una dosis a ocho millones y
medio de personas en argentina y se
habían distribuido más de 12,6 millones
de dosis casi todas aplicadas a algún
ciudadano algún habitante del país
argentina está vacunando con sputnik ve
con la vacuna de astrazéneca y con la de
scinopharm por ahora son las que estaba
utilizando el país se espera que sigan
llegando de todos los proveedores
vacunas sobre todo hay mucha expectativa
con la llegada posiblemente durante lo
que resta del mes de mayo de cerca de 4
millones de vacunas de astrazéneca que
se habían fabricado en argentina pero
que habían volado para hacer envasadas
en mexico y estaba demorada su llegada
al país además de eso eso se espera que
los otros proveedores sigan enviando
vacunas y además el gobierno sigue
negociando con otros proveedores para
tratar de incrementar el número de dosis
disponibles en el país
natalio pues estaremos muy atentos a
como argentina encara este pico de
contagios que ha venido padeciendo ya lo
decíamos desde el mes de abril y que
todavía no logra mitigar muchas gracias
por este reporte desde buenos aires y
miren esta historia es muy interesante
juan manuel manganaro es el presidente
del grupo hamas una compañía dedicada al
rubro de los seguros en buenos aires en
argentina el presidente de esta empresa
de 155 empleados decidió pagarle a sus
empleados que son mayores de 40 años un
viaje a la ciudad de miami en eeuu para
que se vacunarán contra el joven 19 ante
la lentitud del proceso de vacunación en
el territorio argentino natalio co soy
nuestro corresponsal en buenos aires-
conversó con él y esto fue lo que le
comentó de esta idea bueno el programa
inicial para 30 personas
tenían que reunir determinados
requisitos esos requisitos tenían que
ver con ser mayor de 40 años no haber
tenido que tener la visa y el pasaporte
el día para poder viajar a los eeuu y
tener tres años de antigüedad en la
empresa como mínimo
compramos ese paquete de 30 pasajes pero
finalmente pudieron viajar hasta ahora
27 personas solamente porque otros tres
se contagiaron de kobe y tuvieron que
quedarse en buenos aires y la decisión
fue tomada porque a pesar de la gran
inversión que significa para nosotros no
somos una gran empresa una corporación
una empresa nacional que tiene gracias a
ellos una trayectoria una buena
facturación pero una inversión grande
sin embargo nos dimos cuenta que los
directores gerentes o personas que nos
acompañan hace mucho tiempo son
realmente esenciales para nosotros y que
en vez bueno estos años año y medio que
estamos confinados hubo muchos ahorros
que todas las empresas pudieron obtener
y se los estaba mencionando hace unos
minutos chile este país está a la cabeza
en la vacunación en américa latina
también es destacado a nivel
internacional por este mismo motivo
veamos las cifras este país ya ha
inoculado a 17.08 millones de dosis de
vacunas contra el cob y 19 es decir que
unos 7 millones 625 mil 311 ciudadanos
chilenos tal vez ya un poco más por el
cierre de la semana han recibido ya las
vacunas contra el cubil 19 esto indica
que el 50 por ciento de la población ha
recibido la vacuna de un total de 18.95
millones de habitantes
y la situación en brasil en cuanto a la
pandemia no sigue siendo fácil ya lo
habíamos reportado acá las últimas
semanas el alto número de casos no da
tregua además hay otras novedades que
tuvieron lugar a lo largo de esta semana
y hablaremos de eso con valeria saccone
la corresponsal de france 24 en la
ciudad de río de janeiro hola valeria
gracias por acompañarnos aquí en el
programa y bueno destacado esta semana
en brasil- valeria que este país ya
comenzó a fabricar bajo licencia
la vacuna rusa sputnik ve qué novedades
hay en torno a este tema y esto tal vez
podría aliviar un poco la demanda de
vacunas en la región
brasil ya ha concluido la fabricación de
las primeras 100 mil dosis de la baja
una rusa pública hay que recordar que la
anvisa la agencia brasileña del
medicamento nunca aprobó su uso interno
alegando razones de seguridad por esa
razón esas dosis sólo podrán ser
exportadas a los países vecinos de
américa latina'
pero antes tendrán que pasar por la
aprobación del instituto gamma de ella
en rusia hay que recordar que en marzo
la visa aprobó la fabricación en
territorio brasileño elija el principio
activo está siendo desarrollado en el
laboratorio unión química de brasilia y
posteriormente envasado en una fábrica
de guarulhos en el estado de san paulo
en brasil mientras tanto la vacunación
avanza pero a un ritmo lento hay que
recordar que en este momento tan sólo el
19 por ciento de la población ha
recibido la primera dosis si miramos a
brasil en términos absolutos podemos
decir que la situación va bien porque es
el cuarto país que más dosis aplica 40
millones de personas recibieron la
primera y 20 millones la segunda pero si
lo miramos en relación a los 100 mil
habitantes brasil ocupa el lugar 58 en
él
sin mundial valeria estábamos
mencionando los récords de personas
fallecidas allí en brasil esto supera ya
los 750 mil a lo largo de toda la
pandemia de este ya poco más de un año
que llevamos a una emergencia sanitaria
es un tema que alerta a las autoridades
brasileñas porque si bien el segundo
pico en brasil está medio mitigando ya
el país parece que está empezando a
remontar y podría tener un tercer pico
más rápido de lo que se espera
brasil podría enfrentar en breve una
tercera ola de hobby 19 debido a la
lentitud del proceso de vacunación y a
la falta de aislamiento social es una
previsión de la universidad de
washington que calcula que brasil podría
alcanzar en agosto los 750 mil muertos
sin embargo la organización panamericana
de salud hace un cálculo aún más sombrío
y estima que brasil podría alcanzar en
septiembre las 940.000 muertes de
momento brasil camina hacia los 450.000
fallecimientos y tiene registrados ya 16
millones de casos confirmados hay que
decir que después de la segunda ola las
principales ciudades del país han
abandonado las medidas de confinamiento
por eso después de unas semanas en que
las cifras de muerte bajaban la curva se
ha estabilizado y en los últimos días ha
empezado a subir algo que preocupa mucho
a las autoridades sanitarias además se
acaban de descubrir los primeros casos
de la variante india en el estado de
maranháo en el norte del país todavía
son pocos pero por la experiencia que
tenemos se pueden multiplica
y eso es otro peligro y otro reto que
enfrenta brasil
valeria y para el cierre en que va esa
investigación por parte del senado
brasileño sobre la pandemia y el papel
que ha jugado el gobierno del presidente
bolsonaro y algunos de sus funcionarios
semana intensa en brasilia en el senado
en la comisión de investigación de la
pandemia dos ex ministros de jr y
versionar tuvieron que comparecer el más
esperado era el general eduardo para
suelo exministro de salud que llegaba
con un habeas corpus del tribunal
supremo que le permitía permanecer en
silencio para no tener que aportar
pruebas contra el mismo sin embargo para
suelo ha optado por responder a todas
las preguntas pero el relator de la
comisión
renán calheiros le ha acusado de haber
mentido en al menos catorce ocasiones
sobre todo sobre la gestión de la crisis
del oxígeno en manaos y la compra de
cloroquina entre otras cuestiones para
sólo llegó a sentirse mal tuvieron que
suspender la comparecencia y reanudar la
al día siguiente otro gran protagonista
de la semana ha sido el ex ministro de
exteriores- ernesto araújo que tuvo que
comparecer para responder sobre los
ataques contra china y contra la vacuna
china que en este momento es la que más
está siendo aplicada en brásil
corresponde más o menos al 80% de las
dosis aplicadas
él tuvo que responder también sobre
otras cuestiones como la compra de
cloroquina en la india el negó todo dijo
que nunca había atacado a china a pesar
de que los hechos están allí en su blog
llegó a llamar el coronavirus de como
una virus un juego de palabras para
decir que era comunista e les eximió de
todo culpó de todo al ministro de salud
y también según los relatores de la
comisión siguió mintiendo la semana que
viene se esperan más apuraciones está
previsto que hable la famosa capitana
cloroquina es un cuadro del ministerio
de sanidad
la señora piñero que ha sido una gran
defensora del uso de cloroquina un
medicamento que según las autoridades
sanitarias de todo el mundo es ineficaz
en la lucha contra el coronavirus
valeria pues seguiremos a lo largo de la
semana lo que pueda suceder allí en la
justicia brasileña en torno a este tema
vemos ahora un vistazo al avance de la
vacunación en la región de américa o en
el continente de américa como cierra
esta semana algunos de los países de
nuestro continente vamos a comenzar en
ecuador
allí cierran la semana con más de 416
mil casos confirmados de kobe 19 ya
veinte mil cien personas han fallecido
en ese país
bolivia tiene más de 343 mil casos
confirmados y 13 mil 700 personas
perdieron la vida
de otra parte paraguay la cifra de
contagios ya supera los 324 mil y la de
víctimas mortales superan las 8 mil
personas y por ultimo uruguay cierra
esta semana con 253 mil nuevos casos de
kobe 19 y más de 3600 personas han
fallecido
y está con nosotros el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez para conversar con él de
varios temas que tenemos en la agenda
relacionados con la pandemia de kobe 19
doctor pérez tenemos varios varios temas
para usted y quiero comenzar entonces
con el anuncio que ha hecho lado ms que
indicó que todas las vacunas que existen
en el mercado actualmente sirven para
combatir todas las variantes del
coronavirus esa es una noticia positiva
si la mayoría de las vacunas a la
mayoría de las variantes digámoslo así
tenemos evidencia que por ejemplo la
vacuna astrazéneca no funciona una
variante de sudáfrica pero son hechos
que son la excepción y no la generalidad
que mensajes nos está dejando la
organización mundial de la salud es que
vacunarse evita no solamente las
variantes sino que ésta se propague
si bien hay una reducción en la
capacidad que tienen para neutralizar
las variantes no es la gravedad
neutralizar la gravedad de la enfermedad
por eso es importante mantener la
vacunación con cualquier marca en
cualquier país y masivamente es la forma
como podemos mitigar el virus y sobre
todo la aparición de estos linajes día a
día
doctor pérez también fue destacado esta
semana ese anuncio por parte de la unión
europea de la puesta en marcha de un
posible pasaporte o certificado de
vacunación para facilitar la entrada y
salida de viajeros dentro del territorio
schengen dentro del territorio de la
unión europea esto posiblemente pueda
ser copiado en otras regiones del mundo
entre ellas américa latina' por supuesto
incluso al interior de algunos países
que tal le parece a usted la idea como
han evaluado ustedes desde la parte
médica hasta el certificado
digamos que hay dos escenarios que
definitivamente son importantes el
primero es cuando una persona se ha
recuperado de kobe es importante porque
no transmiten enfermedad por un tiempo
tal vez puedan ser seis meses y las
personas vacunadas no sabemos cuánto
tiempo precisamente dura la inmunidad
pero pueden ser de seis nueve meses tal
vez un tiempo razonable esta estrategia
de saber quiénes están vacunados y qué
personas están recuperados permitiría la
movilidad y hacer algunas actividades
sin embargo distinto lo que pasa en
europa y en eeuu latinoamérica está en
una gran incremento de casos y con unas
tasas de vacunación que son lentas y
además de eso erráticas por la falta de
la suplencia de las vacunas entonces yo
creo que esta estrategia podría ser una
estrategia a mediano plazo pero no a
corto plazo distinto en países que están
vacunando a un ritmo superior y sobre
todo lo más importante que tienen vacuna
para para su población nosotros estamos
en un momento muy crítico y creo que es
una estrategia que se contempla al
massae la doctora hay una pregunta
recurrente
en todo este escenario de la pandemia
sobre todo desde que empezó la
vacunación y este segundo pico en
américa latina' que no da traigo a los
países no han podido reducir la cantidad
de casos es muy poco en realidad por
ejemplo pero solamente ha reducido un
26% que es significativo pero pues
todavía no es la luz al final del túnel
y muchas personas se preguntan si las
medidas y las restricciones que están
siendo adoptadas son suficientes vemos
que argentina va a ir a confinamiento
por nueve días más por el repunte que
está teniendo estamos adoptando las
medidas necesarias para poder bajar este
segundo pico que no da tregua ya vemos a
brasil que va a empatar el segundo pico
con el tercero
santiago nuestra complejidad
es
el casi que una mezcla perfecta para que
se desarrollara el coronavirus no es los
confinamientos y las restricciones son
medidas reactivas y son medias cuando
todo ha fracasado nuestro principal
actor era la disciplina social y el
comportamiento sin embargo la misma
dinámica de una sociedad que necesita
salir porque la informalidad laboral en
las dificultades económicas las crisis
que hay sociales en varios países de la
región han obligado que esa disciplina
social que se conoce no se aplique y eso
es lo que llevó la expansión de los
casos américa latina es un ejemplo de lo
que sale mal en una pandemia como
conocimos desde un año como protegernos
pero no lo aplicamos y tenemos que tomar
estas medidas draconianas de
restricciones y confinamientos casi como
una medida última para proteger el
último eslabón que son las camas de
cuidado intensivo y yo creo que nosotros
tenemos que enfocarnos en lo que sabemos
la ventilación de los espacios y el uso
de la mascarilla y sobre todo tratar de
resolver un poco más de esos problemas
sociales para poder evitar este tipo de
aglomeraciones que nos han perjudicado
tanto definitivamente este es el peor
tiempo que tenemos en la región y
también sumado una baja tasa de donación
doctor usted menciona aquí dos cosas
importantes la disciplina social y el
comportamiento eso va en línea un poco
con la siguiente pregunta que de hecho
era una duda de nuestra productora la
productora del programa 'laura garzón
que me decía que ya nota que en muchos
lugares públicos ya no toman la
temperatura cuando la gente va a entrar
ya no obligan a la gente a ponerse un
poco de gel anti bacterial antes de
entrar a un establecimiento público a
algún local a algún restaurante y la
gente tal parece que se está relajando
un poco con esas medidas pero vuelvo y
digo el segundo pico no ha dado tregua
así que hemos hecho en este año pues
hemos aprendido un poco más de cómo se
transmite el virus
hemos visto que por ejemplo los tapetes
la toma de temperaturas fue algo que se
hizo inicialmente pero no tiene una
efectividad que es claramente efectivo
el lavado de manos la degeneración de
las manos frecuentes se debe hacer y eso
evita la transmisión viral lo mismo el
uso de cubre o que es correctamente es
que nosotros lo que vemos es que la
gente tiene un cubrebocas o una
mascarilla pero la usa parcialmente el
aussie regularmente son de mala calidad
utilizan un mismo de cubrebocas
desechable por tres o cuatro días lo
cual pierde totalmente la eficacia una
clave que nosotros no hemos hecho es el
control de los aforos y la ventilación
de los espacios esas son medidas
efectivas hay una medida sin efectivas
que digamos no se han practicado pero
las que conocemos son más efectivas las
actuamos parcialmente por eso esta
indisciplina a continuar estas medidas
pues es lo que ha perpetuado que tanta
gente se está enfermando y seguimos
siendo muy susceptibles porque tenemos
muy
las tasas de vacunación nosotros estamos
incrementando los casos y reservándonos
en vacunación cada vez más entonces el
llamado es a continuar lavándose las
manos a bañarse cuando uno regresa a
casa después de haber estado afuera
expuesto de pronto a condiciones donde
puede estar el vídeos doctor pérez
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí como siempre un placer y
pues un gusto poder aclarar estas dudas
de los televidentes y también del equipo
técnico del programa muchas gracias y en
otros temas el presidente de eeuu joe
biden anunció esta semana que su país
donará 20 millones de vacunas para que
sean repartidas de manera equitativa a
través del mecanismo kóvacs este monto
viene a sumarse a los 60 millones de
vacunas anunciadas anteriormente esta
nueva donación estará formada por lotes
de dosis de vacunas que han sido
desarrolladas por las farmacéuticas
modernas pzifer bayón tec y johnson y
johnson
20 millones de vacunas para donar a
través del mecanismo kóvacs es el
anuncio que hizo ayer lunes el
presidente estadounidense joe biden que
suma a los 60 millones de dosis de
astrazéneca prometidas anteriormente y
que no están siendo usadas en el país
pues no han recibido el visto bueno de
la fd a este nuevo paquete de ayuda
incluye dosis de facer modernas y
johnson and johnson propiciado por la
cada vez menor demanda en eeuu
compartiremos estas vacunas para poner
fin a la pandemia en todas partes no
usaremos nuestras vacunas para asegurar
favores de otros países y trabajaremos
con kóvacs el mecanismo internacional y
otros socios para asegurar que las
vacunas sean entregadas de manera
equitativa y siguiendo la ciencia y los
datos de salud pública director general
de la oms agradeció el gesto de
washington no sin antes haber denunciado
que el mundo está en un apartheid de
vacunas por la desigual distribución el
mundo está en una parte de vacunación
aborto
como saben los países de altos ingresos
tienen el 15 por ciento de la población
mundial pero acumulan el 45 por ciento
de las vacunas y los países de ingresos
medios y bajos tienen la mitad de la
población mundial pero sólo han recibido
17% de las vacunas disponibles para el
continente americano eeuu ha vacunado al
47 por ciento de su población sobre un
total de casi 330 millones una brecha
significativa con países de américa
latina como colombia que tan solo ha
vacunado al 89 por ciento de sus
ciudadanos sobre poco más de 50 millones
el anuncio de yubá idem se da en el
marco de un debate recientemente abierto
sobre la propuesta de liberar
temporalmente las patentes de las
vacunas con miras a producir más
fármacos para combatir la pandemia una
medida que países como alemania rechazan
pero el propio bardem ha respaldado a
continuación veamos cuáles son los
países de la región con la menor
cantidad de fallecidos hasta ahora son
países con poblaciones muy pequeñas
comparadas con otros con gigantes como
por ejemplo brasil o colombia o
argentina
empezamos con guyana que presenta un
poco más de 15.000 casos allí 300
nueve personas han fallecido este país
tiene solamente 700 82 mil 766
habitantes surinam presenta más de 12
mil casos allí 240 personas han
fallecido por kobe 19 surinam tiene 500
81 mil 367 habitantes y de otra parte
nos vamos al departamento de ultramar
francés de guyana francesa que tiene más
de 22 mil casos de los tres es el que
más casos de contagio registra pero en
contraste es el que menos muertes
presenta solamente 110 personas han
fallecido allí cuyana francesa tiene 294
mil 71 habitantes
vamos a ir ahora hasta mexico vamos a
conocer cómo está la situación en este
país y para eso conectamos con mario'
carbonell en ciudad de méxico para
ampliar esta información hola mario
gracias por estar con nosotros y
acompañarnos en el programa y cuál es el
balance general de la situación allí en
méxico un país que se ha librado un poco
de los picos que se están presentando
principalmente en suramérica
así es las autoridades sanitarias
insisten en que méxico registra una
reducción persistente de la epidemia
desde el mes de febrero a la fecha en
todos los indicadores tanto de muertes
como de contagios de hospitalización
actualmente en méxico hay más de 221.000
fallecimientos confirmados por kobe 19 y
de los 4 casos detectados de variante
india en el estado de san luís potosí no
hay ningún fallecimiento se mantienen
igual de tal suerte que el subsecretario
de salud y responsable ante la pandemia
hugo lópez gatell ha estimado que entre
agosto y septiembre méxico alcanzará la
inmunidad de rebaño en su punto más
crítico que es de 75 por ciento de la
población ya con anticuerpos para el
sars co2 la ciudad de mexico que fuera
el epicentro de la epidemia en el país
ya está en semáforo amarillo y
próximamente en verde tan es así que ya
hay fecha para el regreso a clases
presenciales los alumnos podrán estar en
las aulas el próximo 7 de junio en un
proceso escalonado paulatino voluntario
y con estrictos filtros sanitarios
mario y puntualmente cómo está avanzando
la vacunación allí en mexico cuéntenos
el 90% de los más de 2000 municipios del
país la población de adultos mayores ya
está vacunada con el esquema completo el
28 de mayo próximo terminará también la
vacunación de los maestros y personal
docente son poco más de 3 millones de
personas y pues la vacunación avanza el
pasado 19 de mayo se aplicaron 720 mil
dosis esto es un récord para un solo día
en total se han aplicado en el país 25
millones de dosis y en este sentido
bueno el presidente lópez obrador ha
dicho que a este ritmo para el mes de
octubre ya se prevé que todos los
mexicanos estén vacunados al menos con
una sola dosis con una primera dosis
probablemente ya con la segunda para que
antes de que llegue el invierno la
población esté más protegida eso es lo
que ha dicho el gobierno es el nuevo
reto de vacunación
-mario allí en méxico tienen las
elecciones de medio término a la vuelta
de la esquina el gobierno ya ha dado a
conocer algunas de las restricciones o
medidas que van a tener debida seguridad
para garantizar dos cosas la salud de
los mexicanos y que puedan ejercer su
derecho al voto
el instituto nacional electoral en
conjunto con la secretaria de salud y la
secretaría de gobernación han diseñado
un protocolo sanitario con distintas
medidas para la jornada electoral que
consiste en por ejemplo que no podrá
haber más de dos personas al mismo
tiempo en la casilla se procurará la
sana distancia en la fila los marcadores
para cruzar la boleta por ejemplo se
recomienda a la población que lleve sus
propios bolígrafos sus propios
marcadores para no tenerlos que estar
compartiendo en las mamparas no abra a
las tradicionales cortinas que
garantizan la secrecía del voto sino que
se pondrán a una distancia considerable
ya estas medidas recientemente se añadió
el que la población no tendrá que
entregar su credencial para votar al
funcionario de casilla para que las
revise si no simplemente mostrarla esto
y bueno otras medidas como la aplicación
de gel la toma de temperatura en fin son
de distintas medidas que se han aplicado
por supuesto el uso de cubrebocas todo
el tiempo que no lo lleve no podrá votar
y otras acciones que se han tomado de
prevención
gracias mario por este completo reporte
desde la ciudad de mexico y el plan de
vacunación en perú avanza lentamente
como en prácticamente toda la región de
américa latina en estas fases iniciales
fueron inmunizados los integrantes del
personal de salud los bomberos policías
las fuerzas armadas y también los
adultos mayores sin embargo las
autoridades idean diferentes mecanismos
para llegar a los más vulnerables como
por ejemplo hacer el uso de mototaxis
para acceder a los barrios de la
periferia de lima que es la capital
peruana para asi inmunizar a los
ciudadanos que allí viven
esta combinación entre moto y taxi se ha
convertido en una nueva arma contra la
pandemia la mototaxi como se conoce
localmente es un vehículo liviano que
está siendo utilizado para llevar al
personal de salud hacia los barrios
ubicados en lo alto de los cerros de
lima perú médicos y enfermeras bajen los
pequeños vehículos y recorren a pie el
vecindario en búsqueda de adultos
mayores que no pueden bajar a los
centros de vacunación de la ciudad
a la modalidad que nosotros hemos
implementado es la visita domiciliaria
dado que nosotros tenemos muchos adultos
mayores y con discapacidad no es muy
vulnerables que no pueden movilizarse
tenemos la zona de el agustino es una
zona alta
y poder movilizarse hay muchos también
adultos mayores que viven solos este
medio de transporte también es popular
en la ciudad y fue adoptado por las
autoridades de salud para ser parte de
la jornada de vacunación que avanza a
cuentagotas
tenemos firma de perú ya acumula casi 2
millones de casos confirmados de kobe 19
y se ha registrado más de 60.000 muertes
por el virus el país sudamericano
espera recibir este año unos 60 millones
de vacunas y hasta ahora se ha
inmunizado casi al 8 por ciento de su
población muchos de ellos lograron
vacunarse gracias a estos coloridos
principios que desde la llegada de la
pandemia realizan viajes con una
ambición social
bueno ya lo ven todo es válido para
poder garantizar que toda la población
pueda acceder a las vacunas en la región
de américa latina con esto llegamos al
final del programa los espero la próxima
semana no sin antes recordarles la
venció las manos sigan usando el
tapabocas la emergencia persiste la
emergencia del comil 19 se mantiene
sigan cuidándose y sigan con la
programación de france 24 sigan con
nosotros
[Música]